jadav and clowny how does the yanukong
way
trade affect him now let's put this in
perspective
clowney made 15 million last year from
the seahawks
technically eight from the seahawks and
seven from the texans but he made 15
million
he hasn't gotten offered much more than
15 million on a one-year deal on the
open market
he presumably wants 20 or more
yanukongwe gets 12 from the vikings plus
they give up a second round pick
next year and a five that could become a
three in 2022
what do you do how do you value
clowney in relation to what in gaque got
between the two guys let's start there
who do you want chris between genevieve
and clowney or yannick and gawkway
assuming
the clownie is healthy which guy do you
want that's not even close
that's not even close to me you know
again this is where
sacks are overrated uh disruption
f the play up physical mismatch
offense has to change what they want to
do on the offensive side of the ball
clowney causes all those problems
yannick and goku has got a great first
step
and can fly around the edge but after
that i'd go
there's some other issues with this game
he's 247 seven pounds
you know and i think he's got to eat to
like stay that way so he can't take
double teams on he's not great in the
run game it's clowney all the way for me
michael
okay so here's the reality
when because a trade is always done in
relation to
what you have to give up by way of draft
picks or players
what's that value yeah and what you have
to pay the player yeah
so now setting aside that aberration
from several years ago when the browns
bought a second round pick by taking on
brock osweiler's 16 million dollar fully
guaranteed contract and they ultimately
ended up paying 15 because he went back
to denver
for a million dollars after the browns
cut him so they they
paid 15 million for a second round pick
that's an aberration
someone told me last night that roughly
speaking
second round pick is worth eight million
dollars so
the vikings when you take the 12
plus the value of the second round pick
and let's not even try to put a number
on the 2022 pick although
that's justified it's 20 million for
ngakwe
so if it's 20 million for in gaque
what's clowney worth
what should he want this proves chris
that he's justified in wanting 20
million or more
if you regard him and i do too is
healthy he's he's the guy who can
f the play up over and over again right
without ever getting a sack
completely destroy the offensive line
blow gaping holes in it like a torpedo
into the hall
of a destroyer that's what you're paying
for
and if you're gonna pay 12
plus a second-round pick if we attach a
value of eight to it
for a one-trick pony all due respect
you're paying more than 20 for jadavi
and clowny
aren't you no you you are i i mean i
guess where i want to just question
your math a little bit is like yeah but
you're getting that eight million off
the books or you don't have to
pay it either so you have i think you
have to take that
well what do you mean you're getting the
vikings don't have to pay eight million
to a second round
no no no no no it's not no i know the
value of the
value the value of the pick right the
value of the pick
if we if we say what is it if you want
to buy a second round pick for a team
what would you buy it for buy it for 8
million i'm not talking about the value
of the contract because it's actually
less than that yeah i'm
talking about what a second round pick
is worth in dollars and cents
so if we try to mash those together yeah
because i look at it this way
and and we're probably never going to
know this um
but if i'm the vikings and maybe we will
know maybe it's something maybe if there
was only somebody who was a reporter
that was part of this program who could
go try to find stuff like this out
but if i'm the vikings am i not number
one
i want to improve my pass rush okay so
who's out there
well i can trade for yannick and gawkway
or i can sign javian clowny
well i'd like to think that before
giving up a second round pick
plus another pick plus 12 million
dollars for ngakway
i'd like to think i'm talking to clowney
i'd like to think i'm at least finding
out what clown he wants
right yeah you'd be stupid to not do
that
so um the problem is what is he asking
for what is it
like i mean he probably wants more than
a one-year deal
would you give him 20. would you would
you get if you would give and i don't
know that you would give in gakwe
12 plus a second round pick plus more to
get him but assuming that you would do
that
would you rather just play pay 20 to
clowney and be done with it i don't know
if i would not in this current
environment
i don't i'm not sure and you know the
other thing we have to bring up is that
there is an injury
risk with majesty i mean that's right
i know but it's a real fact there's a
risk yeah i mean it just
to me that lowers his price tag to a
degree so
yeah gideon you might be the player
that's worth 20 million
but with your injury history to me that
knocks a few million dollars off of it
you know yeah you were awesome last year
but in
half the year so i mean what what are we
supposed to do there plus we know like
we've talked about before mike
he's had micro fracture surgery on his
knee that's about as bad as it gets for
an nfl football player
you always are a little skeptical
skeptical about ooh
when will that kind of run its course
and really affect his career to where he
can't be the same guy there so
yeah the player this is where it's
really tricky with him because
the player itself is worthy of being
a 21 22 million dollar a year type guy
but there is injury history and now
there's the coven 19 pandemic
and of course the salary cap adjustments
and all that so i don't know i don't
think i probably would pay 20 million
dollars for debian county right now
well um it's an interesting question
i'm gonna start trying to poke around to
see you know
how to turn that into dollars and cents
and what does it mean for clowney and
you know maybe clowney is just waiting
until we get to the first week of the
regular season
he might be and he'll take the best deal
that's available hey he's avoided all of
training camp he's avoided the offseason
program so did everyone else
but a lot of times a veteran player
wants to do that he doesn't want to mess
around with it
he knows what he can do he knows how to
get himself in shape
and he'll be ready to go and uh uh it's
it's going to be an interesting question
now to see if someone makes a run at
clowning and what he ultimately would
get
because you could argue that the vikings
are basically
if we turn it all into dollars going
more than 20 million for one year
with yannick and gawkway and and if
that's the case
if that's the case uh if i'm gonna if
i'm gonna write a check for 20 million
between agakway and clowning i'd
probably rather have clowney
i probably would yeah i think so yeah
i'm with you i'm with you
i guess the other you know yeah the
question is is just who's that team
that's going to pony up enough money to
want to
want a giudivi on clowney and that's
where i just look at it and think it's
interesting
you know there's some teams there that
certainly have positional needs at the
top of like
salary cap and what you know what they
have available
hey there are the patriots there we've
heard the cleveland browns flirt with it
i think that ship
sailed and gone now the jets have a need
there at the position
you know it doesn't sound like they're
going to go there we know washington or
the denver broncos
they're good in that position the
dolphins you know do they want to
flirt with that i mean there's some
teams out there you look at and go it
makes sense the tennessee titans
with the vic beasley situation they have
they've been they've been linked to him
yeah they've been linked so
i could see that the three-four defense
and of course genevieve county played in
houston which is the same scheme as new
england
and in tennessee let me try one more
hypothetical yeah and i know this is
going to be hard to do because
we can't forget what we already know
pretend it's sunday morning
and the text that you get from me isn't
vikings trade for yannick and gawkway
pretend
that the text is viking sign genavian
clowning what's your reaction oh i'm i'm
going
whoa holy cow game changer on defense
i mean there's just so many things
yannick and gawkway wants to line up
three feet outside the offensive tackle
and like we said speed rush
jaedevian clowney is like the jack of
all trades
you can line him up a d tackle and he
could run over quentin nelson
you can line him up at defense end and
he'll run over trent williams
you can play him at linebacker and let
him walk around
and just pick where he wants to blitz
and be a rover and just do crazy crap
he has unbelievable position versatility
yes i would have been more excited
for your minnesota vikings if they got
clowney yes i would have sorry well
doesn't that answer the question maybe i
should have started there yeah maybe
that answers the question
that answers the question so we'll see
what happens with clowney we are
10 days away from the first game texans
chiefs 13 away from the first full
weekend of the regular season and two
weeks away from that doubleheader that
will cap week one
steelers and giants and titans and
broncos it's here
it is here and it is going to happen and
i can't wait chris and we're going to
have you
covered every step of the way at
profootballtalk.com pft live do we have
an unbutton coming up today yup you know
it we're gonna break down some uh
afc over unders as far as what we're
expecting there
break down some uh other news going on
in the nfl and i think we're even gonna
do with some videos of like
some ideas of what new england might do
with cam newton on the offensive side of
the ball and kind of show some uh
you know some some white board pictures
of some plays they might run with him
and his talents there
well bill belichick met with the media
today and he declined to say who the
starting quarterback is as if anyone
is guessing at this point who it will be
all right we'll see you tomorrow on
peacock for pft live check out the
digital clips on profitballtalk.com the
podcast is available
sorry we won't be on nbcsn for a few
weeks but you will find us
anywhere and everywhere and we'll see
you again tomorrow everybody have a
great day see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports